okay all right your boy psychobabble we
are continuing our journey we are
continuing our journey and it's getting
[ __ ] scary that's all I gotta say
continue this [ __ ] continue this [ __ ]
let's say you [ __ ] hate sunset it's
so sad there's a Trank all about you
know this meatball people where did you
hide the radar never tells needless to
say this lady was impressed well play
there man no wasn't comrade gonna get us
some more beers after he helped Flis
[Music]
drank and since he was drunk he forgot
to bring it to us and he just kept on
drinking and he drank all of it sounds
like you've had some experience with
this kind of comrade and plus it are
down there okay so he took it if you
want to check it out Wow okay prego how
does it feel that soon be known as be
mrs. Julia Smith
dad's I've been assuring I wasn't sure
how it would feel but now that I hear it
it does have a nice ring so I guess we
should talk about wedding plans
eventually okay now you're speaking my
language
Oh everything together come [ __ ] fast
I was so worried you might say no of
course I was gonna say yes you dimwit
dimwit and meatball let me tell ya
abusive I could see our whole future
rolling okay it's okay that's fine
she's so happy when her skin is [ __ ]
flawless
I like there's actually some slight tan
lines there was much so what is it
bearing when they talked about it lady
they're both happy no it's like what
happened okay [ __ ] it
hey don't don't kiss him don't kiss him
don't kiss him no I got distracted let's
go get him sure so which one is you know
yours magic happens whoa say nothing
Conrad beers where are they oh yeah the
beers I'll just get them now [ __ ] brah
yes who's here their teeth are that's a
hard to scan right
all right now that everybody's here
let's take a look at the navigators pad
we found maybe we can figure out why the
plane was out here okay I'll go get it
okay well I gotta get it what is this
that's my camera thing right
take a GoPro you turn this [ __ ] honor
and I can't ever mad Oh sent up [ __ ]
Araki service Conrad Islands Oh [ __ ]
hang wrap
[ __ ] gnarly okay let me just
thoroughly investigate this you know
ocular pat-down ocular tomorrow no [ __ ]
I didn't press any or anything near them
just [ __ ] tuck me yeah
seemed a little - what the [ __ ] hey
almost time for barbecuing got the pad
yeah sorry I got distracted noise let's
go get it
what the [ __ ] how's exploring dit got it
let's go up what about all the [ __ ] I
was gonna explore come here you fix it a
vixen oh my god Lizzy tiger whoa get
back [ __ ]
she's skinny and fat that skinny and fat
you'll get no resistance there all right
everyone
check it out manchurian gold who wants
to find some sunken treasure ma so what
do you think captain coordinates those
are coordinates all right
maybe the planes destination you think
we could get there by tomorrow it takes
a couple hours if the weather stays
steady wow do you find anything else
this plane must have been shot down
because it was riddled with bullet holes
I found one lodged in the fuselage hmm
and it was a lot of life raft must have
gotten shot down before they could
deliver all the rafts there was only one
missing reckless all of you excuse me I
told you to leave everything down there
alone oh come on we've been through this
already I'm not talking about the law no
hey they were respectful no you did
whatever you wanted whatever you took it
was too much nobody knows [ __ ] no come
on
no one knows we've even been down there
and I don't think those can talk you
Americans are all the same huh Oh
[ __ ] racist
tradition [ __ ] should have never gone
down to that claim in the first place
it's bad luck you think you can scavenge
down there and it makes no difference
but every single thing you bring back
has an essence it's like a ghost you
invite to the surface here we go huh I
never thought about it like that you
never think about much of anyway well
maybe I never heard about such cool
ghost stories they're not cool ghost
stories not like for fun people drown in
these waters and you have to respect
their resting place
damn straight bread you got a fun ghost
story right let me see what it is um I
think what Alex it is a way up bless
[ __ ] I like it Shay I don't like it it's
you only at this semester
Konrad perhaps just [ __ ] their job
yeah I heard a story happened right
around here - let's hear it we could all
use a good show let's hear it [ __ ]
let's hear it I bet you can spin a good
yarn it's kind of messed up actually
scare away a little boy okay here goes
this story is true it had happened right
near here in an old lighthouse classic
setup wait
true story where'd you hear this if you
need to know it's ripped right from the
rotting pages of the terrifying ancient
in-flight magazine I was perusing on our
way here the lighthouse stood atop an
atoll isolated from the rest of the walk
and lava awesome beacon in the night a
sailor's respite the lighthouse keeper
would hear the waves pounding the rocky
shore one misty morning he comes upon a
woman covered in blood just stumbling
down the beach he hurries to her aid and
she falls into his arms sobbing as he
hurries her back to the light yes where
she's from he doesn't waste any time it
smooth puck he of the one-track mind
the woman answers I live here in the
lighthouse
my parents are upstairs right now twists
of course the lighthouse keeper says
that isn't so of course he's lived there
alone for years and the woman becomes
hysterical and it's just her parents are
upstairs so they go to the top of the
lighthouse and they're splayed out on
the floor it's a man and a woman rudely
murdered with an axe always an axe I
mean do people even use exes anymore I'm
just reporting the facts cliches an all
chopped up into little tiny giblets
templates
so gross
okay so who did it so the woman she's
still hysterical says her husband did it
and he's still here in the closet huh
the husband a so is this a warning 12
future brides hey no back seats you're
locked in so the lighthouse keeper
creeps over to the closet
opens the door and sure enough there's a
man inside but he's cut his own throat
dad what the [ __ ] he was closer to see
the dead man's face in the dark closer
closer and he sees it's his own face and
then it's eyes bulge out and screams
nice one Squire you have me goin pretty
cool hit me on the cheese there corn dog
okay what's that man you've all had your
fun we should all turn in there's some
weather hitting are we oh no no no
because according to standard vessel
regulation we're all required one more
beer before hitting they are these
obviously institutional protocol
division where'd you read the internet
oh so you found a website that tells you
to drink beer under every circumstance
I'm just following orders man I'm in
this website dude what the [ __ ] now
let's get the [ __ ] out of here whoa
- oh wow
what the [ __ ] aren't they like heading
home they're just like [ __ ] it right
this is [ __ ]
this is [ __ ]
it's just [ __ ] my [ __ ] dogs out
all right
no it's the people oh it's people are
earlier
okay
this guy's gonna get [ __ ]
yeah we're flus at
unless today - yes I always late even an
hour such as this this [ __ ]
ungag this dead
come on [ __ ] doing it oh [ __ ]
- [ __ ]
well badge
I got this [ __ ] oh my god my honey bear
okay I think so
like why you'd be able on gag [ __ ]
get my place
almost free
well good news bad news news how's the
office could get any worse bad news is
these are kind of maybe the fishermen I
pissed off earlier oh god damn it
Conrad raids just great it's [ __ ]
recognize how was that good new husband
you're gonna ask the good news first or
such an idiot
Jesus hey are they gonna do to us
[ __ ] wise personality really kill us
they would have done it already
not just worried about being killed
being raped we gotta get some tie this
[ __ ] there's a guy
[ __ ] dodge that [ __ ] what I gotta
press now is a nobody knows they're out
here living lady you all alone with us
now let's make the most of it you can go
[ __ ] yourself you piece of [ __ ]
you're the little lady
little
give me a chance to [ __ ] lock
my god
what are we gonna press
hey well what do you [ __ ] want
a cigarette ad the knife
slow down
hey Barry
I'm saying that
we did later patient relaxed
okay I'm pretty good huh
he's like you just got me wet okay
okay compliant cunning reckless
[ __ ] [ __ ] hurry
oh Jesus Conrad is a [ __ ] block hi
come on get the [ __ ] arrest on time
stick shut the [ __ ] up they don't care
that he's like I'm tired I don't think
they're gonna hit her they have an
influence sure seems to be getting
buddy-buddy with him
she's my brother yeah
no but I'm sure he's fine
these guys probably just want money or
something all right let's get this [ __ ]
reckless and patient cunning Wow don't
let me see your hands back don't they
[ __ ] now you can sit here smack down
the window like you stood at the window
they're coming
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I'll tell that [ __ ]
hey hey okay look II told you I'm fine
they didn't touch me they asked about
her parents what how much money they
have safe a lot I'm sorry
what does it took my ring Julia it's
okay it's okay that's so [ __ ]
are you saying well the thing keeps
changing every second
a pair of scissors [ __ ] style now we
just have to wait and see what they want
to do with us
you know Flis is not money
eight seconds
storms eight miles away they gave me
here on a boat there really a mile
saying yeah yeah it's a speedboat he's
got a gun
well at least one of us can get on their
boat get some help
I can get about if you can distract them
I can get on that boat the dude with a
gun won't even realize until I'm long
gone seven seconds I can get out through
the window we gotta break these off
first did you loud they'll hear it we're
gonna break on during the thunder oh
that's what I'll go through the window
and get the boat you guys distract them
I feel I literally wait it's just like
seven seconds
you think what'd he do
[ __ ] there we go
go [ __ ]
no his [ __ ]
this is real [ __ ]
[Music]
get that [ __ ]
drop it buster it's amateur fuckless I
got this
let me handle it
this is so [ __ ]
think about what you're doing oh just
get to the boat
it's kids trying to kill me or sir
escaped [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] I gotta press
they're gonna shoot that fish
this is [ __ ] anything it's [ __ ]
gone bring them downstairs beat this use
it if you have to
sit down over there
you right here sit
no I hate people deco simoom back to
stop film blah used to be important okay
this is [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
I'm Tony this is [ __ ] oh no they're
gonna eat the chili Olson
come here
which one of you is going to tell me
about this Manchurian do I have less
well it's all her idea we told her not
to touch anything
so I haven't [ __ ] late wasn't so
bright outside
Connie could take care of himself all
right shut the [ __ ] up
Wow
I ain't [ __ ] you know what I like
nothing that's right nada
complete [ __ ] silence Wow
I'm just gonna say it this has got to be
in on this
she needs guys they travel in the same
waters she's the captain and they barely
laid a hand on her
I bet you told him about the Manchurian
goal there it goes
that's [ __ ]
you're all in this together this is a
trap and you set us down so put a cork
in it put a cork in a [ __ ]
since - oh yeah the [ __ ] boat just
ran with me like that fluffs girl all I
got a thing
find out how long the storm is gonna
laugh
you try anything anything
and any consequence
okay
Lucas Milan requesting weather update
Oh
that's great
you're gonna play that way
the [ __ ]
she knows how to play this game
[ __ ] nuts
what do I got a pressed bench
hey what's this [ __ ] doing right here
No
thanks I guess
anyone know about Brad is he hiding
somewhere
say nothing [ __ ]
okay listen hey where's Pratt better
let's hit him [ __ ] like ten years
right stays hidden better off down there
than with these psychos
oh yeah great you could get killed down
there
that's a big boy okay there's probably
better for us if he stays put for now
let's a generous relax okay
holy [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] everyone still alive things could
have been quite different Wow
you appear to have saved somebody a bold
move that paid off this time but does
this make the rest of your group more
vulnerable now no no yes say we'll find
out hmm yeah I agree yeah you know well
find out kind-hearted creature I am I'd
like to offer you some forewarning of
what's to come
tempted
okay there clémence will turn to the
bard for inspiration The Merchant of
Venice act 2 scene 7 the Prince of
Morocco pulls a scroll from the eye of a
skull and reads all that glisters is not
gold often have you heard that - never
heard that one anyway vicious you've
reached a point of significant distress
I presume you're eager to get back to
your story but here's a thing well
what's a thing everything may not be
entirely as it seems
probably shouldn't have said that
that's [ __ ] anyways thank y'all and
say y'all the next one okay okay